boeing's pilot training is under
scrutiny today's investigators analyzed
data from the Ethiopian Airlines crash
that killed 157 people CBS News has
learned US pilots were given initial
training of 56 minutes on an iPad about
the differences between the new Boeing
max planes and the older 737s we have
also found out that new evidence shows
similarities between the Ethiopian
Airlines crash and the lion air crash in
Indonesia back in October
both crashes involve those Boeing max
Jets Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan
National Airport outside Washington with
more on this story Chris it's very
disturbing to hear 56 minutes of
training on an iPad good morning good
morning Gail certainly the training is
going to be part of the larger
investigation here now we have also
learned here at CBS News that employees
at both the FAA and Boeing have been
told by federal authorities to retain
records dealing with the approval
process for the 737 max this involves at
least one subpoena now that's happening
as on the other side of the world the
Ethiopian transportation minister told
reporters there early data from the
black boxes of flight 302 showed
similarities to the crash of another 737
max 8 in October satellite data also
showed the flight patterns between the
Ethiopian Airlines and Lyon air flights
to be similar we've learned physical
evidence found at the crash scene in
Africa leading to the FAA ordering the
max to be grounded included a jack screw
which helps lower or raise the nose of
the plane it was set in a dive position
in a statement Boeing CEO says the
company is finalizing its development of
a software update as well as a revision
to pilot training to address concern
concerns stemming from the lion air
crash Congress is also planning to
investigate the approval process for the
737 max now French investigators were
able to completely download the contents
of both black boxes including the one
that had been damaged that information
has been handed over to Ethiopian
investigators who are leading this probe
the FAA NTSB and Boeing are
participating assisting in that in
negation Gil yeah the more information
we get the better but Chris what are you
hearing about how long the max planes
will be grounded in this country well
Gail this could stretch on weeks
potentially even months a lot of it
depends on where the investigation in
flight 302 goes right now we don't
necessarily know enough to say if there
are additional issues beyond what that
software fix is supposed to address from
the lion air crash at the bottom line
the FAA has said the max will not fly
until that software fix has been
installed and proven to address all of
the problems all right Chris thank you